I like to imagine that if somebody had
come to the people who were inventing
connectionism in the first you know sort
of perceptrons and neural networks and
so on if somebody had come to them and
said oh by the way sorry you know we're
with the biologists we we got it wrong
it's not the thinking isn't in the brain
it's in the liver and so then the
question is what would they do right
what would they have changed anything
about what they're doing and we said ah
now we have to rethink our model or with
his fine who cares uh this is exactly
the same the same model everything works
just as well so I often I often think
about that that question what exactly do
we mean by by neurons and isn't it
interesting that we are able to to steal
most of the tools the concepts um uh the
Frameworks the the math from
neuroscience and apply it to problems in
other spaces so not movement in
three-dimensional space with muscles but
for example movement through amorphous
space right anatomical morphe space